esto convencer a los indecisos ese era
el objetivo de los candidatos a la
cancillería alemana pocas horas antes de
la votación tras 16 años en el poder
angela merkel decidió dar un paso al
lado de su cargo sin embargo este sábado
estuvo acompañando a su candidato el
conservador armen glass quien perdió
popularidad en los últimos sondeos
merkel fue enfática al decir que la sed
de ser elegido daría continuidad y
certidumbre al pueblo alemán
ustedes deciden sobre su futuro gobierno
y este futuro gobierno creo que todos
estamos de acuerdo debe garantizar la
prosperidad la seguridad y la paz es the
heights refri de son oms y eso es por lo
que estamos aquí porque nosotros en la
unión democratacristiana les estamos
haciendo esa oferta el anio vota por su
parte el candidato de la unión
democratacristiana aseguró que los otros
partidos en pugna traerían inestabilidad
alemania
singer y let's standing jets lucha
tenemos que usar las últimas horas para
decirle a cualquiera que tenga dudas que
si buscan estabilidad en alemania la cdu
tendrá que estar en el primer lugar
austral
linda
al otro lado del país en postdam cerca
de berlín quien ahora es el ministro de
finanzas olaf scholz también se lanzó la
tarea de convencer al electorado la
cabeza de los socialdemócratas llevó a
su partido de liderar las encuestas por
primera vez desde 2006 en campaña firmó
varias veces que le daría a alemania un
nuevo comienzo pese a ello es muy
probable que el candidato debe formar
una coalición para gobernar con el zombi
en lo que respecta a la coalición quiero
decir explícitamente que la coalición
que más me importa es la de los votantes
porque cuanto más fuerte sea el spd más
fácil me resultará formar gobierno pero
según los últimos datos el partido
socialdemócrata le dio una ligera
ventaja a la unión democratacristiana
mientras que el partido verde quedaría
en tercer lugar